can I just tell you something that
happened to me there yet today this
morning so I can't get into detail about
it but I booked an ABC pilot okay and I
um I shot last week and this morning I
had to shoot at 5:30 in the morning and
I'm on set I had to pee and they said
upstairs was the VIP bathroom okay
from this hell was shooting in the house
so I go upstairs and I pee in the
bathroom about to pee in the set dirac
decorator walks in she goes hey not
supposed to be up here I go because I
know as soon as she confronts me I know
fun is about to happen you love this I
love when confrontation that happens
because then I play it the other way she
was this is only for you know me series
regular you know mean the you know mean
background is on the other around the
corner just by your I look like
background if you don't know Bobby Lee
it seriously if you don't there's no way
they're gonna put this on TV you have to
note enough there's no they put everyone
on TV yeah but we got flat my em come on
be real though I completely agree
because it happens to me all the time
right am i right okay you're yeah we're
like a cameraman or
sound not even that just because I left
because that's exactly how I feel it's
terrible yeah so what happened if you
say hey oh no no no you got to make it
weird
yeah spectacle so I pulled my penis back
in because that was out yes amid Pete
almost Pete I was about to pee and she
from behind right okay so I will go
downstairs and I go to the head
you know min ad or whatever Aiko I could
have stopped it by saying no I'm on the
show yeah and then just went on my merry
way I'm done no I I thought you said
that upstairs because it is ope get the
shoot you know mean like you're calling
you upstairs she's sitting I can't be
just she goes up there oh good I hear
all this like commotion oh that's great
I'm down there smiling at the ceiling
hearing what's going on and then I walk
up and then just like an IP oh my god
probably the same thing happened when I
did that you'd still what Steve Glickman
showed that he did that that boyband
show on Nickelodeon oh yeah I forget you
know that it's they're called they were
a boy band or they had his own and
Nickelodeon show I know but anyway I
guess started on that and when I showed
up the lady goes you're in there so I
stayed in a extras stable she just for
like an hour a stable it was like 50
people or I just wasn't anything I knew
I wasn't supposed to be there I could
have just said no I'm guest star and I
just sit there with them and the whole
hour I'm just full of Glee because I
know there's gonna be a moment of like
[Music]
you know man that whole thing all right
that's the way I live that's why I
haven't killed myself you know what's so
funny though I feel like that's a very
la thing like they they treat you based
on what they know you from so when I did
this small thing for my friend they're
shooting like this youtuber I think I
can't really talk about that but they I
got on there can you talk about it
because I'm not supposed to yeah I was
supposed to talk about I did they
literally
you don't follow the rules he does yeah
I'm just saying he's gonna say this
they literally the network email me
don't ever talk about the pilot yeah and
I just said it but that's fine but then
again they also told you not to show
your penis yeah and so um they talked to
me very rude you know as if like I'm
just trash and garbage you know I came
in from my friends yeah and so it was
just a very small possible speed this
bartender and I just asked the producer
I was like my spot was very small I was
like oh do you know a rough time of no I
don't know okay you know I'm like oh
then do you know can you can you direct
me to somebody who does know she goes
look I already told you I don't know I
was like do you even work here you know
so I was getting a little irritated yeah
so I was just waiting that whole time
and I everybody was kind of treating me
like I'm just like that side character
so I was just wondering I was like okay
so I just got Tesla I took my car I had
drove it up to the front I drove it up
to the front exactly the move that's
what you should that's what he said yeah
and so when I did everybody comes up yo
that show website I'm like what I can't
do I get off [ __ ]
and they're like oh so you so you're not
just an extra cut extras don't got that
stuff literally said it no shame
whatsoever yeah and there's now they're
talking to me like I'm a human being
did you like water I'm like good la whoa
nobody offered he was yeah
gross and I'm gonna tell you the my I'm
gonna say something right now and I'm
not just looking at me I'm not when I'm
working on anything I talked to that I
don't give a [ __ ] who it is
yeah I talked to the [ __ ] the guy
that's doing the nail I talked about
yeah I like today this guy
[Laughter]
[Applause]
but like that was a there's a guy that
I'm just saying my point is is that I
don't have that I don't give a [ __ ] oh
yeah you know me but people like people
have this when they're given a little
power they start mouthing off when they
don't know the full information mm-hmm
and those kind of people yeah but then
you're really snooty with extras in what
way okay I'm that's the only one I'm not
nice to see because if it goes down the
chain he's being abused by one so he has
to abuse another no that's not true
cycle you just know that's awaiting the
cycle of abuse that's not true because
to me all right if an extra believes
that he knows what he is I can tell they
keep to themselves they do what they do
right it's only when they cross the line
and they think that you guys you're both
on the same thing it's good working with
this together you know me oh no I was
approved by the network the president
right you showed up you know you don't
listen I would just say that it's the
same thing and I okay maybe maybe it's
the same thing is open Micra it's like
you think that Chris Rock right and some
guy that just did it for a week is the
same but that happens it's like when an
open Michael will walk up to me and I'll
do some disguise bringer show but but
close it out and I see this open Micro
came up to me goes I'll see you I see
you around the circuit he said that to
me
[ __ ] MC [ __ ]
you talk to me like that
[Music]